hallo leute ich zitiere mal ran und
willkommen zu einem neuen
adventskalender auspackt video heute
testen wir den sozial engagiert
adventskalender von ab wenn zorn
schlimmsten wortspiel mit osten sein und
ganz ehrlich für wortspiele bin ich
immer zu haben auch wenn ich nur eine
schlechte wortspiele machen eure kritik
ist angekommen ist waren sehr sehr viele
beauty adventskalender mir ist das im
nachhinein dann auch aufgefallen obwohl
ich die ganze zeit dachte dass ich voll
verschiedene anwender habe aber ich habe
hintereinander so viele beauty
adventskalender ausgepackt weil ich die
verlosung im hinterkopf hatte und
unbedingt alle ausgepackt haben wollte
damit ich alles noch pünktlich verlosen
kam also falls ihr mir nicht auf
instagram folgt wird die kalender die
ich ausgepackt habe füllen
beziehungsweise habe ich das schon
gemacht und werde sie halt verlosen
nicht mit dem original enthält sondern
mit meinem durch gemischten inhalt ja ja
aber weniger müll produzieren wird bevor
ich anfangen muss ich eine sache
erzählen ich so kann nach einer wohnung
zusammen mit meiner besten freundin die
nach berlin zieht und ich habe morgen
eine besichtigung für eine wohnung die
einfach nicht die ziehung die ecke die
ist wirklich ich werde mir nicht meine
jacke anziehen weil ich wirklich nur
kurz rüber laufen sie mir anzugucken und
ich wollte schon den ganzen sachen
dieses video drehen aber ich habe es
einfach nicht hinbekommen weil mein herz
so sehr hasst und ich so aufgeregt dass
falls ich jetzt irgendwie komisch wirke
das liegt daran dass ich so aufgeregt
wie noch nie in meinem leben war okay
ich glaube ich war nicht mehr für meine
eigene wohnung so aufgeregt wie für
diese wohnung sollte so gut getarnt ist
loszulassen wir fangen jetzt mit dem
unboxing und alle leute die diese zweite
kammer da nicht
es tut mir leid ich liebe sie sehr und
mir die man geschrieben worden ist ja
voll der hektische schnitt dadurch aber
ich dachte mir so ist das nicht völlig
normal bei mir und die leute nicht
mittlerweile gewöhnt ist bei mir
wirklich sehr hektischen schnitt geladen
wir fangen gestand bahnchef dieser
herren da ist wirklich wunderschön
gestaltet also ich meine guckt euch das
an das ist mit aquarellfarbe durchsagen
designt gemalt entworfen worden und ich
glaube hier steht die künstlerin
illustrated bei carina kuklinski also
von nina bublitz gebe gefällt das design
absolut und befolgt den auspacke wir
haben einen brief bekommen wir haben
einen drews gekriegt wer einen brief
gekriegt ich frage mich wo von geben so
hießen advents um sticker das sind nur
pass kann das sind mehr postkarten das
wird nur postkarten die sind aber auch
sehr schön
erst da auf diesen augenblick freuen wir
uns ein feedback angefangen haben den
adventskalender zu planen also dieser
adventskalender ist gefüllt mit stars
mit sozialen projekten mit allerlei
guten dingen und ich bin wirklich sehr
gespannt weil ich ein letztes jahr schon
gekauft habe aber in letzter sekunde
verschenkt habe also ich weiß nicht
wirklich was drin ich brauche halt dass
er noch schnell geschenkt
denn recht wenn er die wird euch zwar
warum gut also kam sehr gut an harald
wir haben ja schon mal umschläge mit
zahlen drauf das wird auch türchen des
[Musik]
crucis gestaltet der ist hans verpackung
türchen nummer 1 geschenkt auf mein gott
ich bin schon weihnachtsstimmung ich hab
so lothar weihnachten startup nummer
eins im heutigen türchen geht's rund
aber es gibt ja schnell power um den und
dem nachmittag steve keine chance
kugelförmige leckereien auf das basis
wigan glutenfrei und ohne zucker zu sein
als die verpackung für die schon mal
extrem gut wir sind dann drei mal solche
packungen drin aber jetzt geht es
absolut und hayes testing gut aus wie
ich ihn sehr nach erdnuss
diese mit erdnussbutter gefüllt wie
würde ich mir nach kaufen weil durch die
holen wollte mal erdnuss foto zum
letzten mal gucken was adventskalender
gekostet hat ganz billig war dann die
mich nicht ich muss mich raten an einem
kommentar in der sich gewundert hat
wofür ich dann mein geld ausgebe
beziehungsweise wie ich denn mit meinem
geld umgehen weil ich mich nicht an den
preis von dem adventskalender ändern
konnte von dem nagelstudio auf das
geländer sowie der kalender gekauft als
ob ich mich eine jeden preis den ich
bezahlt habe radvan 99 euro oder das ist
doch mal ein stolzer preis und er ist
nicht mehr auf lager wann ist er sich
einfach die geilste am westerländer vor
der nase wegschnappt ok also wir denke
ich mal sachen preise mussten sozialen
adventskalender sich bisschen schlecht
anfühlt einer erdnuss kostet sechs euro
das ist das ding beim hochwertigen
sachen die kosten einfach immer eine
spur mehr türchen nummer zwei sause die
seifen krause flüssigseife ohne durch
zehn tabletten zehnter werden kann man
ein liter seife herstellen kernseife
stück und timo hier so blöd 2 wartet zu
machen also wir haben im gästebad und
den haupt part aber jeder hat quasi so
sein war dadurch ja ich weiß das ist
musik linke auch irgendwann hat ihm und
seifenspender so einen stinknormalen
verkehr mich nachts immer weil man diese
nach hüls ecke kaufen muss und ich finde
es schade weil dann hat man ja trotzdem
wieder so übelsten plastik sagt den man
dafür verschwendet das ist irgendwie
gerade so geil hat kostet die seiten
brause nochmals 16 16 euro türchen
nummer 3 seine erste zum cocktail auf
der nächsten party ich tatsächlich ist
aber die vorstellung dass in der
schüssel schon ganz viele partygäste
gefühlt haben
in sachen hier drin also braucht man
wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht 100
im leben aber kommen also hier füllt man
die ernte so zum beispiel rein und wenn
du dann wieder drin hast was du diesen
mechanismus rutter blum ist doch super
oder und ganz gleich geschlossen und hat
wieder ein schrei packen
er ist mega versuche mir vorzustellen
wie es da doch leute jetzt dass hier auf
meinem kanal wieder sagen warum es so
gesehen war dann hat es ausgepackt und
vorgestellt holt euch jetzt den snack
unterstütze hier startups aber dann muss
ich an dieser stelle sagen dieses videos
nicht gesponsert und jetzt alle dieses
videos nicht gesponsert ja mehr muss ich
dazu jetzt nichts sagen oder 15 euro 49
küche nummer vier und ich glaube türchen
nummer vier ist ein broker karo ev seit
25 jahren kämpft karo ev für diejenigen
die verkauft missbraucht diskriminiert
und gequält werden durch die spende von
advent advent sind sämtliche kosten die
für eine unserer schutz unterkünfte
anfallen ein jahr lang gedeckt dafür
sagt das 14-köpfige carotin von herzen
danke frohe weihnachten für dich und
deine linie müssen wir noch gucken ob
der kalender sich finanziell lohnt ich
glaube das tut er das hätte anders aber
gleichzeitig so so schön dass man mit
diesem kalender einfach auch
gleichzeitig etwas gutes tut ja okay wie
kommen wir da jetzt wieder raus wir
suchen die türchen nummer fünf aber
nicht ich brauche menschen so war dann
machen wir zweiter in die türchen auf
die gucken was dazu drin ist ich meine
wir haben noch drei briefe vor uns ich
glaube das wird sie eröffnet passieren
wie in eine liebevolle umarmung gehört
das beschreibt das gefühl sich in ein
handtuch einem bademantel oder kuscheln
wir ein es ist so unglaublich weich kosi
bay nature und holz holz ist da auch
drin mit verarbeiteten die holzfasern
sind saugfähiger weicher und auch
nachhaltig als baumwolle ein handtuch
kostet sechs euro
bis jetzt bin ich mit den produkten sehr
zufrieden sie wieder nach was aus was
pamela reiss sehr gerne ist white chalk
einmischen kann sheen lukas oft klingt
so gut weiter
ich kann also wenig schokolade ist weil
ich einfach keine milch vertragen und
dann ist halt weiße schokolade auch
vollrausch optisch sind die so schön aus
er wird den verein riedel pflanzt man
einbauen
das ist ein super organik regeln aber
ich brauche das etwas ein wenig süß
schmeckt und da habe ich das gefühl dass
ich gar nichts sicherlich etwas nicht
mag zwar etwas soziales das sagt denn
der preis für zwei euro aber schreibt
noch gerne auf den riegel kennt und
vielleicht auch eine andere sorte besser
schmeckt weil white chocolate crunchy
nut mit handzahm schmecken jetzt nicht
so gut mache weiter mit dem nächsten
türchen nummer sieben war dass diese
fische mit den grund
lappen fisch also von jean und long
short und long philosophie sehr geile
handcreme ohne gedöns vegan für
strapazierte sehr trockene hände
geschmeidig wien rochen lauren davis
hall mit intensiv liegenden urea und
frischem rosmarin ginger dürfte mein
gott du wirst riechen den braten ein
veganes brathähnchen sorg bisschen was
die hand ich hatte nie so geschmeidige
handle
diese handcreme es ist das erste mal
dass sich eine fünf sterne bewertung auf
eine verpackung wäre aber ich glaub das
ist mittlerweile normal man ja die
handcreme ist genial
die einzige haben creme die ich kenne
die schnell einziehen und meine
trockenen hände pflegt 3089 ich bin
schockiert ich habe irgendwie mehr
erwartet weil das so fans die aus sind
und so schön verpackt absolute
empfehlung dijon und klebte nummer chips
aus karton damned kopfball an schmecken
so gut sieht halt dass bananen sind die
haben die perfekte konsistenz ohne
palmöl ist gras drauf okay leute
missbrauchen
zwei euro 75 aber andererseits sind sie
okay ich mal
ich liebe diesen keinen natürlichen ein
jawoll oha
das schöne großen tafeln zartbitter ich
kann es gibt so eine schublade aus
niederlanden tommy es geht auch so einen
komischen nicht normalen ja das sind
halt keine normalen stücke sondern so
crazy kam es zum test
diese beratet kammer aber ein stück
denkt den bedarf das ist eine richtig
reichhaltige zart bitter schokolade
schmeckt super bewusst 70 prozent also
hat die booms aber wenn ich ende immer
8% oder lodi prozent hungerlohn 70
prozent des cola gar nix was kostet 79
euro und man es aufmacht dann sieht man
was für ein hilfsprojekt man unterstütze
wir wollten uns jetzt hier haben einen
brief gekriegt wir haben einen brief
wir haben einen brief bekriegt ich frage
mich schon von wmi von teach one ev ist
ein community basiertes bildungs und am
powerman projekt in berlin ausgehend von
beginn als bücherei und archiv hat sich
eros arbeit auf die expertise und
arbeitsbereichen literaturen
kulturvermittlung jugendarbeit anti
diskriminierungs beratung und monitoring
interessenvertreter und vernetzung und
internationalen zusammenarbeit von
schwarzen menschen ausgedehnt als träger
der kinder und jugendhilfe sind
besonders wichtig junge menschen als
aktive beteiligten in den schwarzen
communitys zu verstehen in die
gestaltung des vereins mit einzubringen
und manchmal das finde ich mir
ich bin gerade so schockiert weil das ja
genau das ist was wir brauchten kindern
einfach schon geholfen wird und nachdem
wir uns nun wieder sozial engagiert
haben was übrigens ein sehr gutes gefühl
gibt und wieder ein türchen nummer
dribbeln und das werde ich glaube ich
mich probieren mit wasser auffüllen und
genießen mit wasservögeln und genießen
jetzt mal riechend probieren kann ich
nicht weil ich mich gut aber ist eine
spannende sache das ist kein free press
trade
das so man kann es in der flasche und im
beutel kaufen und es ist nicht vorrätig
ist es etwa ein heißer scheiß hier die
euro für seine rekordzeit in limbach
dass sie den so tierisch aus das makro
krakau raspeln ein topping aus 100
prozent bio kakaos bin es beschert die
einzigartigen genuss momente und ist
vielseitig einsetzbar harmoniert mit al
dine 12 o cacau bedeutet 100 prozent
kakao oder wie ich habe in meinem leben
noch nie 100 prozent kakao gegessen
also als topping
ist es bestimmt lecker weise das hängt
mit allem zusammen wenn man das jetzt so
1 und ist total strange war dass wir
ebenso gewürzt schmeckt also sieht auf
jeden fall sehr schön aus und kann ich
mir gut vorstellen
6 euro 90 man merkt dass dieses rohkakao
halt sehr dort in schokolade drin ist
aber das was man schwenker sowie
geschmack mal 100 nummer 13 ich wohne
ich löwenzahn vegane honig alternative
das produkt ist nicht von bienen als
rudolf strich oder zum süßen und kochen
backen rohrzucker wasser löwenzahn
extrakt als erstes muss ich wissen was
das jetzt kostet dann honig ist sehr
teuer
und wenn es eine gute alternative gibt
die nichts wird heuer ist machen sollte
man da noch honig kaufen etwa 94 das ist
genauso viel wie hunde sind das jetzt
schmeckt riecht nach honig leute kommen
wir denn da hin
das hat die konsistenz das sieht
original aus ihr honig
wow das ist dass das das ist lecker
wasser zum ganz ganz leichten karamell
liegen geschmack jährigen deutschen
karamell den geschmack aber durch das
blumige hatte ich es probieren würde
würde ich jetzt nicht sagen moment mal
das ist ein dass hünfeld honig das ist
honig demo wird zur veganen honig
probieren riegel halle ist vegan honig
zu werden nicht von bienen ich beende
dafür helfen meinem ganzen leben darauf
gewartet jetzt diesen regionen honig zu
probieren kraftwerk als original
berichtigte zucker wasser und löwenzahn
extrakten wir zu tisch kommt damit so
die hier nun mal würfeln meist rising
vegan kein plastik das ist hier
mittlerweile glaube ja klar dieser
lippen ist wie aus dem anderen kalender
komplett aus pappel man hat hier seine
papier stand der mann dann zieht und
fertig jetzt na gut werden probleme
sätzen wie ihr könnt es jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht so gut sehen aber
dann ist dann hier eine schnur und an
der zieht man dann zieht man sie sich
den lippen beiden immer weiter frei ist
eine coole den lösung fünf euro
16 es ist halt schade wisst ihr was noch
das große problem ist bei so guten
produkten was sie nicht so in der masse
produziert werden können dass deswegen
eine mahnung stolzen preis haben aber
sie finde ich gut dann kommen wir zum
thema 53 ist caro mein gott ist das gut
voran erfrischende minze pflanzliche
zutaten kein zucker das ist das einfache
rezept für forrest gump
statt plastik steckt in forrest gump der
saft des skiclubs leute vorher muss man
muss sich wirklich mal gedanken darüber
machen jemand so eine packung extras
sind halt ganz praktisch und so sie im
auto zu haben das tut doch nicht weh
einfach besser reiter type zu kaufen
eher sagen wir zwei euro pro packung
türchen nummer 16 wir haben einen brief
gekriegt ich frag mich nur von wem loya
bonobo als wir über langen gala fanden
weil der hydrid schwachen traumatisiert
mit den spenden von anwendungen können
wir die rettung eines weiteren bonobo
babys sowie dessen versorgung und
rehabilitation rehabilitation ein ganzes
jahr in finanzieren man.etr kalender
türchen nummer 17 helleres of duty und
natalies mission die gesetze der
schönheitsindustrie radikal verändern
uns wird vorgegaukelt dass wir makellose
körper möglichst viele produkte mit
chemischen inhaltsstoffe noch nicht
komplett braucht er face und body
kokosnuss kohle und erdöl
also riechen tut es sehr gut schenkt dem
h stärke und volumen
die kokosnuss kohle reinigt die haut
porentief und reguliert die
talgproduktion ideal für normales bis 21
und fettiges haar also einfach für alle
bereiten eur 95 roz 98 natürlich nochmal
18 leute lasst uns hier mal einfach mal
weitermachen
ich habe schon viel von essbaren davon
gehört
ich habe noch nie einen essbaren löffel
in meiner hand gemeinsam setzen wir ein
zeichen für eine plastik freiewelt.net
cool aus also wir haben hier drei
fahrstufen hellen mittel und dunkel
cacau masala und klassik weist eine ecke
ab okay weil ich will ihnen eigentlich
wirklich mal so richtig benutzen oder
die hsg was ich meine zähne nicht
essbare löffel leute da steht zukunft
schmeckt in guter hafer kekse man kann
auch mal normal das besteck benutzen
überlegt gerade in situationen wo ich
noch ein plastiklöffel benutzte außer
wenn ich essen zunehmend vergesse den zu
sagen dass ich kein besteck haben will
dann kriegt plastikbesteck dreier park
probiert zwei euro
ein löffel ein euro unruhe das ist das
schwere kombucha ich weiß dass in
amerika computer ein großes ding ist
aber ich weise sie wie sind deutschland
ist roger original ist fermentierte
scaroni sierte stegen trainig habe
kampusch in new york eine flasche geholt
weil in amerika redet irgendwie jeder
darüber muss man auch aufpassen weil das
so ein bisschen zischt das stimmt
irgendwas ist leute kamen gut schmeckt
als auch das abgelaufen wäre es riecht
als auch abgelaufen wäre mir sind
stückchen und geschwungen ist das noch
ein stück lebendiger antraten seiner
premium ja lebendig schmeckt er ein
liter kostet zehn euro
ich muss leider sagen dass diese
stückchen die aussehen wie so quallen
drin und die 1
und wirklich nicht meint sind da war das
computer was ich in new york besser
nummer 20 lasse lakritz natürlich neckar
weißem mehl ist die erste zutat
erwachsene lakritz kein kinderlachen
alle die jetzt kein lakritz mögen ein
sorry ich finde es sehr lecker vier euro
90 ist okay aber es schmeckt sehr lecker
aussage natürlich 21 15 21 sehr leid um
mein gott ich liebe dieses popcorn
ich liebe es popcorn mitterrand
kanonenkugel war vor allem da machen wir
sind was wir vom tisch essen
das passiert im maxi kam er kurz auf
märkten mit schön aus und so bei 390
dafür kann man sich das auch selber
machen obwohl nicht opfern machen das
gar nicht so leicht ich versuche es
immer wieder
ich kriege es nie so schön der alten
sich unser letzter brief hier eine
geschichte
wir haben einen ich frag mich nur von
wem die seniorin ist vorne drauf
ein herz für rentner vor
ich lese sind einfach vor augen nachdem
tevez selbst in heimen aufgewachsen war
wollte sie ihren kindern liebe und ein
geborgenes zuhause schenken wie sie es
selbst nicht gekannt hatte dies mit
einem job unter einen hut zu bringen war
für sie als alleinerziehende eine
tägliche herausforderung oft war sie am
rande der verzweiflung wenn nachts um
zwei der wecker klingelte und sie an die
frühchen der post zu erinnern an das
ging es nicht geld verdienen konnte sie
nur während ihre kinder in der schule
waren oder schliefen knapp 800 euro
rente bekommt die heute 80-jährige
deutschlandweit beziehen rund 93
millionen senioren darunter sogar 70
prozent frauen eine rente von unter 900
euro
weil das vorne und finden nicht reich
wandelt er es sich an ein herz für
rentner
unser verein unterstützt bundesweit
rentnerinnen wie sie die sich nicht
einmal das nötigste zum leben leisten
können mit fatalen auswirkungen die
seniorinnen brechen auf der straße
zusammen weil die zuzahlung für
bestimmte medikamente zu teuer ist
sie sähen nicht gut und verletzten sich
weil eine neue brille das schmale budget
übersteigen
wir frieren in ihren wohnungen um
heizkosten zu sparen oder verzichten auf
abruf noch immer tritt aus scham kein
geld zu erzielen sich viele aus dem
öffentlichen leben zurück vereinsamen
mit den advents um spenden über 5000
euro können wir den rentnerinnen ein
paar sorgen ab nimmt zum beispiel die
kosten zu einem lang ersehnte
zahnbehandlung nebenkosten nachzahlung
oder den kauf von möbeln elektrogeräten
kleidung oder fahrkarten im namen
unserer rente sowie unseres teams
ich hab' ich weiß nicht was es mit mir
ist und das ist guido den kann ich
gerade mich sprechen ich weiß nicht was
mich trennt man ist
falls wir den ein oder anderen euro
diese ist ja auch noch übrig habt ein
herz für rentner ev mitbestimmt spenden
an
okay wir haben einen brief etc nächstes
mal schaut doch dieser band kanada sich
preis nicht belohnt hat okay genommen
bisschen zweifel hier noch häufig sei
dass in der fondation soccer sowie hier
nochmal 23 und was bekommen wir
uhrmacherei wie ebenso auf die frage ob
man diese sehr schön artig waren sicher
dabei werbeblatt hafer habs nur fünf
zutaten mandl hier mag es wenn sachen
solche also papierverpackungen gehen
einem einfach das gefühl wie auch bei
dem popcorn wo sind die papier
verpackung dem einfach das gefühl das
ist irgendwie gesund ist und nachhaltig
und sowieso super toll so oft an wie
hier
quelle sind das fünf jahre solche
energie balls die kennt man also stop
natürlich nie unsere erdnuss baut sie
sind immer noch mal ab hinter favorit am
dieser richtig lecker so wir sind es bei
24 angekommen leute und nun da ihr schon
durch die ganze adventszeit durch gehabt
weil ich das leid der welt richtig vor
augen gehalten wird was ganz gut ist
manchmal 24 wir freuen uns dass es in
der 24 drin
handmade blende zucker ich brauche eine
neue seite also so ein stück seife
leider die riecht als auch die ins das
ist pures zimt wake up szene mit
ich habe aber irgendwo gesehen dass man
das nicht da sind direkt auf seiner haut
kann sind aber wirklich in irgendwelchen
die einwahl video zu seife habe ich
gesehen dass sie mit gesagt hat sind
direkt auf die haut ist nicht gut auf
jeden fall sehr schön aus sie riecht
sehr intensiv sehr nacht sind ich sag
dir liegt nicht reden weil ich wirklich
hab ich keine zeit für das kürzlich mit
spülmittel meine
was ich sehr freudig anfühlt dann
wirklich sehr heutig sieht sehr
qualitativ hochwertig aus normale user
sein für die die ganzen raum nach zimt
erfüllt und somit ist der
adventskalender leer und wir haben jedes
türchen geöffnet wirklich sehr schön ich
glaube wir brauchen gar nicht über
diesen adventskalender preis
leistungsverhältnis mäßig reden oder das
wäre einfach respektvoll ja schöner
hälfte richtig gefährlich wurde echt
überrascht obwohl ich dachte dass ich
schon alles im leben kenne also ich bin
meint ich dachte ich bin allwissend
sorga so super den kalender gibt es
leider nicht mehr zu kaufen aber merkt
euch den auf jeden fall fürs nächste
jahr vor wenn man spannt er ist ein
jedes jahr ausverkauft würde gern wissen
wie viele talente sie meine verkauften
sie arbeiten schon seit februar darüber
nach welche auch kalender rausbringt
genauso weiter länder das wehrheimer
falls jemand so einen kalender
produzieren kann
meldet euch wird dabei - bis zum
nächsten mal eure hände hauptsache sie
waren liegt bei bonobos aber bereit
[Musik]